welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this has been a huge year for
star wars between the mandalorian
and the clone wars amazing final season
really really good star wars content
that has
really restored our hope for this
franchise's future the future that
hopefully soon will allow us to actually
visit galaxy's edge without having to
snatch vader's respirator mask for
breathable air
one of the questions i often get asked
is hey boss i'm sitting around with all
this star wars stuff to stream and it's
cold and scary outside
and i'm like is there a question in
there also how did you get my personal
phone number and you're like yeah yeah
my question is what order should i watch
all the star wars in
also i'm banging you x fool got a lot of
fans in boston it is a great question
a question at the heart of every fan of
star wars a series
initially introduced out of
chronological order and one later
instructed to us by george lucas to
watch in an order different in the
release order add that to the fact that
we also have the mandalorian and clone
wars and rebels to fit into this
timeline and dave filoni apparently
considers it very important that we know
what ahsoka's owl was all about so in
this video i am going to explain how
these different viewing orders change
the whole meaning of how you experience
this saga
and introduce you to some new alternate
watch orders that you could try instead
because none of these watch orders are
really perfect
we're gonna do our best to fix that for
you in fact i'm gonna break down five
star wars watch orders that you can
consider let's start with
the simple release order my go-to
suggestion for any new fan who has never
seen these is to try your best to watch
it in the order lucasfilm initially
released each installment
so that these setups and the payoffs the
foreshadows and the callbacks hit as
they were creatively constructed to hit
so here you start with the original 1977
star wars
and then empire strikes back then
returned to the jedi and then episode 1
the phantom menace attack of the clones
revenge of the sith then the force
awakens
then rogue one then the last jedi then
solo then the rise of skywalker now if
you want to add the tv series to that
release order
after revenge of the sith you'd watch
the clone wars 2008 animated film and
seasons one through six of the clone
wars then seasons one
and two of rebels then after force
awakens rebels season three
after rogue one rebels season four and
then after solo
star wars resistance seasons one and two
if you're interested in that
then the mandalorian season one and then
after the rise of skywalker watch clone
wars season seven
and then mando season 2. but if you
really want to be committed to
this release order path and pretend
you're a star wars fan discovering all
this stuff in the 80s 90s and otts like
we did
after a new hope you can watch the star
wars holiday special and then after
return of the jedi
you can watch those two ewok adventures
movies i mean how else are you truly
going to appreciate those blurts in the
mandalorian
and then you should read the 90s
expanded universe novels to best
appreciate thrawn
starting with timothy zahn's heir to the
empire then you must must must
find a screening of neat joe black and
watch only the preview trailer for the
phantom menace and then
walk the f out before brad pitt hits
that second card by the way you gotta
watch all the teasers and trailers for
all movies especially that one for the
force awakens it was a big deal in our
lives also you gotta be sure to read
son of dathomir read shattered empire in
chuck wendig's aftermath books
read ahsoka play knights of the old
republic play all the games including
the story campaigns for both
battlefronts jedi fallen order do and
read everything because somewhere out
there some [ __ ] commenter is going to
act like he knows more than you about it
okay okay we're going overboard here but
if you just stick to the films and tv
series the problem some will say with
the release order is that
some of those post-release re-edits by
lucas's team over the years have
forced a kind of chronological watch the
big one is that final shot of return of
the jedi
the force ghost of anakin played by
sebastian shaw
in the theatrical release was
controversially altered
to be that of hayden christensen in a
re-release
anakin from the prequels not the face
luke just emotionally connected with
when he
unmasked his father but i would say
other than that weird moment i think
you're overall pretty okay watching
everything in release order but of
course when george lucas released the
prequels he was pretty insistent
recommending us to watch the movies in
chronological order
so let's take him at his word and add in
the tv series here we go
chronological order you basically take
episodes one through nine in order but
then you add in
all of clone wars after attack the
clones and then after revenge of the
sith you add solo
then rebels then rogue one then a new
hope and then
after return of the jedi you fit in
mandalorians seasons one
and two then resistance if you want and
then the sequel trilogy
and if you really want to be nerdy about
that knights of the old republic is set
long before phantom menace that would go
first in the chronology
fallen order would go after revenge of
the sith and then after return of the
jedi would go those aftermath novels
and we did learn galaxy's edge at
disneyland is set between
the last jedi and the rise of skywalker
but you can see why this is weird right
no one's first installment of the star
wars saga should be the phantom menace i
am sorry
and you cannot make us wait that long to
watch a new hope
not only does this order spoil the
greatest reveal in film history darth
vader being luke's father
it also ruins other things like yoda
revealing himself
not as a bumbling swamp idiot but as the
actual wise master that luke is looking
for it kind of ruins the sense of
mystery of whatever those clones ben
kenobi was talking about
it makes it super awkward to watch leia
kiss luke an empire
after learning that they're brother and
sister also there's that appearance of
morai in the final scene of clone wars
it would mean
nothing this way because you haven't had
the benefit of watching rebels to give
you that context yet
the one kind of cool thing we get in the
chronological order in exchange for all
that
is the genuine shock of seeing palpatine
transform into
his scarred and disfigured self but i
would also argue that transformation is
really more fun to watch because of the
dramatic irony we feel
knowing the freaky demon he will be in
return the jedi but
before we continue with this i want to
just take a moment to thank our sponsor
who helped us make this episode
lucy so lucy is on a mission to decrease
the
harmful effects of tobacco through their
new nicotine gum
lucy is a discreet better tasting
alternative to get nicotine
started by two caltech scientists who
spent two years
rebuilding the whole idea of nicotine
gum from the ground up they actually
have three flavors there's a wintergreen
cinnamon and pomegranate they also just
added nicotine lozenges in a cherry ice
flavor
i myself am not a smoker but i do have
some good friends who are and are really
trying to quit i actually gave them lucy
as a way to avoid the whole nastiness of
smoking that they're trying to kick out
of their lives like you know they were
tired of having stinky clothes or a bad
breath after a smoke
they loved this stuff and the cinnamon
was actually a favorite flavor of the
ones i asked and again lucy's mission is
to reduce tobacco-related harm to zero
by
creating a future where nicotine
products can satisfy adult tobacco users
without tobacco
we all know smoking is bad for you and
that is why lucy created a better
tasting product that you can use
anywhere indoors while traveling or
while watching a new rockstars video
just be sure to use the code
rockstars to get 20 off all products at
lucy.co that's l-u-c-y.co
and use the code rockstars to get 20 off
all products
and warning this product does contain
nicotine nicotine is an addictive
chemical you should only be using it if
you are a smoker but if you're a smoker
you know how important stuff is so get
on it thanks again to lucy these issues
with the chronological order is how we
got
the infamous machete order a reorder
proposed by blogger rod hilton in 2011
in this order you start with a new hope
and then empire strikes back
and then attack of the clones he
suggests slashing phantom menace
altogether after attacking the clones
then revenge of the sith and then jump
back
ahead to return of the jedi back in 2011
hilton hoped to kind of
erase from our memories jake lloyd
anakin and jar jar midichlorians the
trade federation naboo conflict and all
that stuff with anakin's virgin birth
and then hilton actually later
recommended watching 789
in order after returning to the jedi and
then you know if you want watching
phantom menace rogue one solo clone wars
rebels everything else is a kind of
anthology supporting material in any
order that you want now my problem with
the machete order
is no star wars feature film can be
erased from canon folks
and that is truer than ever now because
of what i
call this filoni renaissance of all the
interconnectivity of the clone wars
series rebels and now
the mandalorian and it's not just maul
we're talking about phantom menace has a
lot going for it the pod racing vfx are
awesome
qui-gon is a dick to the jedi order
there's some really cool foreshadowing
of palpatine's whole plot in the
prequels
so let's try to build on this release
order is still my recommendation for all
first timers like when i have kids
that's how they're gonna watch them
while i play with their star wars toys
here are my priorities as we try to
assemble a new star wars watch order
one it must include all feature films
and clone wars and rebels in the
mandalorian
like you can consider the tv and
streaming series secondary but not
optional and i i don't want to hear it
you do have the time to watch them you
are someone who watches star wars videos
here on youtube personally i consider
resistance to the optional that's just
me and the games are great but
also optional date in whatever order you
want second priority i want to try to
preserve
the big twists and reveals as they were
originally intended by the filmmakers
so more catharsis more tension and
release less all-knowing dramatic irony
and then third for better or worse
all movies must be lucasfilm's current
versions the ones most widely available
to stream
it's just not practical to try to track
down 1997 special editions of the
original trilogy
or bootleg that terrible re-edit of the
last jedi i'm sorry we're just gonna
have to work with force ghost hayden and
greedo mcclunky
so with these goals in mind i have
constructed four
seasoned consumers of star wars content
two
new star wars watch orders based on what
type of narrative focus
you prefer from this fictional universe
the first new order i
am calling the skywalker order i was
gonna call it the jedi order but uh
that's already a thing in star wars so
the skywalker order puts
front and center the story of the
skywalker family the jedi in the sith
everyone who's got a lightsaber it's
really a watch order for all of us who
have purchased lightsabers in our
lifetimes and like to make home noises
when we knock over lamps
the skywalker order begins with what
else of course the story of luke and
vader in
a new hope and then of course that
mythology deepens in the empire strikes
back but
then after vader's parentage is revealed
we take a cue from the machete order and
we jump back
to the anakin origin story and we
include the phantom menace this time
then we follow that along to attack of
the clones followed by
clone wars now i know what you're gonna
say there's still that mori issue
that you are a season watcher you have
already seen this stuff so you get it
then we go to revenge of the sith and
then rogue one
which does include one of the best vader
scenes
leaving us with a kind of nice balance
of empathy and raw fear of that villain
as we return to his redemption story in
return of the jedi
now then we follow the legacy of these
original trilogy heroes in the force
awakens and then follow that through in
the last jedi and the rise of skywalker
the rise of skywalker has interesting
returns of lando calrissian
and a surprise return of han solo which
i think would make a nice transition to
solo and that movie has the return of
maul which would make for an interesting
shift
to rebels a show that features ahsoka's
return with those white sabers setting
up her
big return in the mandalorian and i'm
doing it this way because i really think
mandalorian works best if it comes after
clone wars and rebels
there's just too many awesome easter
eggs from those shows that are in the
mandalorian and helps to have seen those
first and with mandalorian
i think that is the best place to end
this skywalker watch order because right
now it seems like the mandalorian is
really looking ahead to the future of
the jedi with characters like grogu and
ahsoka now i will admit not everyone
watches star wars for the lightsabers
right especially when that whole
arthurian monomyth kind of drowned in
its own bloodlines in episode nine
a lot of us also just love star wars for
the wars
and with that in mind i present to you
our second option the rogue order
this order begins with rogue one now not
a perfect film but
an awesome one still beautifully shot
probably my favorite star wars ending
contextualizing this universe from the
ground level
in a way that reminds us that you don't
have to be a chosen one or part of any
important bloodline to make a difference
we follow that with of course a new hope
dovetailing perfectly on rogue one's
ending but
before we follow luke and vader into
empire we get a truly
rogue shift here stay with me rebels
next
rebels keeps us in that kind of
uncertain galactic civil war time and
forces us to get to know more foot
soldiers in this war and it kind of has
that immediate
rest quality that the original star wars
film had and i like following rebels
with
solo which not that great of a movie but
it does feel like a really good
live-action episode of rebels right then
after getting this han solo lando
prequel
we get the han solo lando movie with the
empire strikes back but that movie ends
with vader getting revealed which is the
best cliffhanger of all time but really
just because that whole movie ends with
the fact that the rebel alliance is in a
real route
so in that uncertainty we jump back to
the dawn of this age of militarization
attack of the clones and then we follow
that with all of clone wars because now
we get the benefit of ahsoka
and that whole morai bird in the final
scene and really you'll just notice with
this list i'm trying to space out the
longer tv series by sandwiching them
between three or so movies
okay so after clone wars perfect
opportunity to pick up with revenge of
the sith those events are all coinciding
but then after revenge of the sith is
another
rogue shift going back to phantom menace
it's a bit weird i know but trust me i
recently rewatched phantom menace
directly after watching revenge of the
sith
and all of that tragic context makes
phantom menace such a darker better
movie
and now in this structure phantom is
kind of a penultimate episode origin
flashback and we follow that by moving
on to the galactic civil war finale in
return of the jedi now the mandalorian
works as a perfect successor to
returning the jedi
because in this order it's also still
following rebels and clone wars and
also now in the show it looks like
there's more than enough details to
foreshadow the rise of the first order
so then we can close out with the sequel
trilogy
but we go in this order force awakens
then the rise of skywalker and then
the last jedi why do i rearrange those
well the rise of skywalker is a much
better successor to the force awakens
than the last jedi is honestly in the
rise of skywalker it feels like jj
abrams pretended the last jedi didn't
really happen anyway like imagine this
you follow rey handing luke his old
saber on achito but then
you leave what followed a mystery we
don't get that snarky toss
just yet instead we go straight for
machito at the end of the force awakens
to rey training in the jungle in the
rise of skywalker it is kind of a fun
transition that makes sense in a tonal
way
obviously there's some plot details you
would have to overlook but you already
know what happens who cares tonally rise
of skywalker
is the spiritual successor to the force
awakens the last jedi is really the bold
thematic
pivot that looks forward so that is why
this rogue order ends with the last jedi
which
whatever you might not have loved about
that film it remains a beautifully shot
war film that like rogue one puts a
spotlight on
nobody's just trying to make a
difference in that war
effort so there you have it there are
five alternate watch orders including my
two
new orders for experts trying to
rearrange things in the way to
prioritize certain thematic elements
now you might want to pretend one or a
few of these movies
didn't exist that's not me for me it's
all canon
and depending on what order you now
watch it in you might find new things
that you'd like about how everything
fits together so let me know which of
these watch orders you like the best and
you can support this channel by checking
out our various apparel and merch
options at newrockstarsmerge.com
subscribe to new rockstars hit that
notification button
follow me on instagram eavos follow new
rockstars thank you for watching bye
[Music]
you